eu vim aqui apresentar um sonho e como
eu acho um pouco difícil traduzir sonho
palavra eu achei mais difícil ainda
colocar alguma coisa de imagem de
powerpoint
então por mais que a gente tenha sido
lindo aqui disponível eu decidir falar
com vocês e levar vocês por todos os
passos daquilo que eu pessoalmente
acredito hoje que é o futuro do que vai
acontecer imagina que não existe esse
país é fácil se a gente tentar não é
difícil
essa é uma partidinha da letra de uma
música do john lennon em 1971 que chame
média que quase todo mundo conhece e ela
foi criada no contexto de um mundo
dividido no mundo cortado no meio onde a
gente tinha capitalista de um lado tinha
bloco comunista do outro tinha certo e
errado guerra pós guerra
a gente tinha um mundo absolutamente /
ideologia por língua por moeda por
fronteira e por absolutamente tudo
a consequência disso é que era muito
difícil a gente atinge o outro se o
outro não fosse muito parecido com a
gente
no fim das contas até os movimentos de
migração que aconteceram nesse período
eles foram bem complicados os meus avós
vieram para o brasil por meio de
foragidos da guerra civil espanhola e
quando eles chegaram aqui eles não
falavam português
minha mãe não falava português eles não
tinham dinheiro era muito difícil
em 1971 enfim até recentemente na
verdade ninguém falava nenhuma outra
língua que não a língua mãe muitas vezes
o dialeto mãe o que quer que seja então
tudo estava acontecendo porque porque é
a filosofia inteira do mundo estava
baseada num modelo que é para eu ganhar
necessariamente alguém precisa perder
era um esquema de ganha perde sempre
eu só ganho se você perde ele só ganha
se alguém perde era contexto de guerra
tudo tem um vencedor e tudo tem um
perdedor
o que estava causando no fim das contas
e causa na verdade até hoje porque a
gente ainda não chegou em um processo de
união completa
causa separação
a gente não consegue entender o outro
porque a gente não consegue chegar no
outro a gente não consegue enfim se
comunicar e no meio desse contexto todo
começaram a surgir alguns movimentos
movimento artístico que se baseia
bastante no que diz essa música
alguns outros movimentos científicos ea
gente vai encontrar na matemática e na
economia
uma mudança de olhar muito grande com
relação a isso
em 1950 de um nerd público tese de
doutorado dele em basicamente ou a visão
dele ea comprovação dele era totalmente
diferente daquilo que a transmite vinha
defendendo desde a riqueza das nações eu
não vou entrar nos detalhes mas
basicamente para eu ganhar mas eu
preciso fazer o melhor para o meu grupo
porque isso vai gerar um resultado maior
pode ser que eu individualmente não
ganhe mais mas o grupo vai ganhar mais
se eu pensar coletivamente com o grupo
todos nós vamos ganhar então não
necessariamente para todo mundo ganhar
alguém precisa perder essa é uma mudança
muito grande muito sutil é matemática
que têm implicação econômica começaram
têm implicação na nossa vida todo santo
dia e na verdade ela tem um pressuposto
muito grande pressuposto da é o consenso
eu preciso que as pessoas juntamente
decidam que elas vão fazer o que é
melhor para o grupo
se eu tiver certeza disse eu fizer o que
é melhor para o grupo também todo mundo
vai ganhar
e aí na verdade por conta desse consenso
o desdobramento foi enfim em áreas
começaram a surgir formas de você
colocar como que esse consenso seja
seguido por exemplo em política a gente
teve e ainda tem diversos tratados
protocolos convenções e o que quer que
seja que basicamente dizem como que
países vão atuar sobre determinada
matéria guerra privacidade de dados na
internet o que quer que seja
dentro desses protocolos já está pré
definido todos nós concordamos que vamos
agir dessa maneira o protocolo social é
uma coisa antiquíssima etiqueta regras
de etiqueta é um protocolo
todo mundo chega na mesma mesa lado bom
estou no jantar um chique que a gente
precisa começar o salário de fora pra
dentro
essa é a taxa de água e certa dose de
vinho esses são os protocolos que a
gente já conhece e dentro da tecnologia
começaram a perceber que também é
necessário protocolos o que aconteceu
nesse nessa evolução tecnológica da
revolução de pensamento enquanto a gente
tava nesse período de guerra fria tinha
o avanço tecnológico muito grande um
desenvolvimento e pesquisa para tentar
desenvolver alguma coisa afinal de
contas era um contra o outro e nesse
encadeamento de pessoas tentando
desenvolver foram que foi criado um
negócio de cinco letras que é um
protocolo chamado tcp/ip que o
desdobramento dele foi o que hoje todo
mundo conhece como internet foi pelo
consenso do protocolo tcp/ip que
conseguiram chegar à conclusão que era
assim que os computadores precisamos
comunicar
então em 86 quatro anos depois do da da
consolidação e da adoção daquele
protocolo como é aquele que vamos adotar
a gente já tinha pessoas num lugar do
mundo acessando bibliotecas em outro
lugar do mundo e então a gente teve a
internet acabou a guerra fria 91
finalizou
efetivamente ea internet que era uma
grande possibilidade de comunicação
global uma ferramenta de comunicação
global começou a ser adotado em massa
hoje no brasil a gente tem mais celular
do que pessoa e de celular e 50% são
smartphones ou seja a gente com certeza
tem pelo menos 50 pessoas acessam
internet todo santo dia e toda santa
hora do celular
a gente não tem noção como que isso
impactou as nossas vidas porque na
verdade a gente vai vivendo a evolução a
minha filha
nasceu agora já sabe fazer assim e assim
no meu celular
ela sabe que só apertar o botãozinho do
meio vai aparecer na telinha ela sabe
brincar com o cocó com a galinha com um
pouquinho ela sabe ela não tem nem dois
anos
a gente vai aprendendo isso num processo
muito evolutivo a gente foi vivendo a
coisa a gente não parou olhou por pra
olhar porque o que mudou na copa de 98
eu lembro que eu já estava conectado é
uma das poucas pessoas conectadas e
tinham pessoas querem falar comigo pra
enfim falar sobre o que tinha sido o
brasil na copa e as pessoas me
procuravam pelo cqc e as pessoas falam
comigo várias línguas que não fazia a
menor idéia ideia em 2002 foi a minha
vez
então eu precisava achar alguém da
alemanha para falar sobre a final da
copa
eu achei alguém da alemanha eu falava
alemão não vou falar um pouquinho de
inglês
eu comecei a tentar que deu certo e aí
todo mundo percebeu que precisava falar
inglês que todo mundo falava um
pouquinho de inglês e aí no fim das
contas não é nossa língua mãe não é a
língua que falo melhor língua conforme
melhor é português mas a gente começou a
ter uma união de língua e eu conseguia
chegar em alguém da alemanha na mesma
hora
além da transmissão da tv a gente também
tinha internet a gente tinha a partir de
então uma forma de comunicação global a
questão inteira que apesar de a gente
ter unido muita coisa a gente já tem
consenso sobre muita coisa ainda tem uma
parte que está no esquema antigo do eu
preciso ganhar e para eu ganhar alguém
precisa necessariamente perdendo quando
a internet começou a se desenvolver
e quando eu comecei a conseguir comprar
na china ea china começou a conseguir
entregar no brasil o que eu preciso
fazer além disso é preciso pagar quando
a minha avó migrou para o brasil e
depois ela decidiu voltar para a espanha
e levar as coisas dela o que ela
precisava fazer ela precisava
transformar o dinheiro dela o dinheiro
brasil em dinheiro espanha como que a
gente faz isso de uma maneira que a
gente não coloque 50 milhões de
intermediários no meio que vão cobrar
taxas absurdas
e acabar com o nosso pequeno dinheirinho
porque a gente perde tanto no meio dessa
dessa tentativa todo esse estudo todo
começaram a surgir algumas iniciativas
elas são bem recentes pelo menos do
ponto de vista do que a gente tenha
formalizado e divulgado para o público
começou a surgir uma idéia de que porque
que só um processo uma transação do
jeito que ele quer porque cada banco faz
as coisas como eles querem
porque se eu for mandar dinheiro pelo
hsbc assim ser formada pelo etau por
exemplo é daquele jeito porque que eles
que definem as regras porque é preciso
confiar nele
não porque o banco central regulamenta
bacana vídeo que aconteceu com o hsbc
recentemente eu quero mandar dinheiro
para o nepal pra ajudar as vítimas
ele vai demorar tempo para chegar e vai
custar muito caro se eu mandar um dólar
não vai chegar um dólar com toda certeza
nesse contexto todo de ver tudo muito
muito unido em várias pessoas com regras
muito diferentes a gente ainda não tem
isso dentro do mesmo sistema
dentro do medo uma mesma regra que vale
é igual pra todo mundo
no meio desse contexto começaram a se
desenvolveu que hoje a gente conhece
como cripto moedas crypton protocolos
criptorquidia que seja que são
basicamente protocolos consensos de como
a gente vai processar a transação o
consenso dentro de um protocolo muito
conhecido que é o bitcoin ele é o
seguinte uma transação eu preciso
respeitar a privacidade de dados de uma
pessoa não posso saber que helena mandou
x para a avó dela mas eu posso saber que
helena que é dona da chave a
isso no privado a chave a mandou pra
chave b tanto e todas essas chaves
transacionaram eu sei quanto
transacional dentro desse protocolo no
mundo inteiro em tempo real sem eu
consegui reverter nenhum tipo de
transação eo que é melhor não é uma
pessoa que o processo não é uma regra
se um dos processadores de repente foi
preso sumiu nossa teve um branco
o golpe tem problema nenhum porque tem
50 outros processados ao mesmo tempo uma
rede transparente 100% rastreável eu não
sei quem são os donos das operações vai
ter o carimbo dinheiro sem noção que
isso pode mudar
é o fim da corrupção
é o fim da lavagem é o fim da gente
pagando porque faz errado e é o começo
de um jogo de ganha ganha porque afinal
de contas se a minha avó que agora está
com 78 anos na espanha precisar de
qualquer ajuda eu vou conseguir fazer
chegar pra ela
instantaneamente apertando o botão do
meu celular inclusive a minha filha de
dois anos pode fazer entre nessa
história toda é exatamente pelo foco do
que eu decidi fazer a minha atuação
profissional
eu decidi que enfim falar de direito é
muito chato e é muito difícil falar de
direito aplicado novas tecnologias é
mais difícil ainda
eu precisava falar sobre direito dentro
desse contexto que acabei de explicar
para vocês é muito difícil então comecei
a trazer um lado mais fácil e com isso a
gente acaba tendo acaba encontrando as
pessoas mais espetaculares envolvidas
nesse meio
no meio desse contexto acabei conhecendo
que é o bitcoin que são outras crypton
moedas e no meio desse contexto eu
passei a acreditar também que essa é na
verdade a evolução ea consolidação de
todas união que já aconteceram em vários
outros meios e agora a gente precisa tão
urgentemente para o que é o
processamento de transações
exatamente por conta disso que eu espero
que todos vocês possam se unir a gente e
fazer desse mundo finalmente um só
obrigada